[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on va son côté qu'il avait pas vu non si
tu me connais je suis pas moqueur je
reviendrai donc pas sur ta copie des
autres
christophe galtier l'entraîneur n'est
qu'un bout de l'île et fabien galthié
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france de
rugby qui joue très bien au foot il ya
quelque chose
d'ailleurs c'est lui qui m'a dit de
passer le bonjour à l'animateur gustave
courbet que je salue sans aucun doute et
à l'humoriste marcel proust et il sera
bientôt spectacle qu'ont les embrasse
sympa ça hier vous avez parlé de ppda et
sur ce plateau il ya quelqu'un qui aime
ppda qui en a parlé avec douceur je
parle bien sûr de raymond qui circulent
dans les médias et dans la télé qu'on
s'inquiète si sa carrière elle est finie
il est racée l'a75 et caraméliser les
carbonisé retraite tranquillement ta 70
c'est ce que tu vas revenir portant le
voile et le loto c'est fini frère rentré
tranquillement son parcours
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle était cuisinier de raymond vous
connaissez l'expression c'est pas celui
qui parle le plus fort qui a raison
cyril je te demanderai de rappeler cette
exposition à jean-marie ma carrière à
cause d'un livre avons perdu un preneur
de son de cette émission
d'ailleurs on avait une caméra sur lui
regarder la catégorie des gens harris
absolument getty j'ai une tite
d'insuffisance cardiaque et jia d'avoir
67 ans il ya trois que je vaux moi je
pense qu'il est à la fois utopique et
liberticide ce se passe a dit à nous
mettre une puce comme le monde si shia
imedi immédiatement identifié situé
vacciner ou pas le pays qui vous
accueille
il sait que étant vaccinez vous n'irez
pas inonder les encombrer les
réanimations de ce pays parce que parce
que on est toujours contaminants même
sens en élection qui me courent dessus
un cheval un truc de 70 kg ha ouais avec
une gueule comme ça toi matin et me
foncent dessus et pour me rassurer
le maître au loin et dis n'ayez pas peur
il a joué
lawrence kuhn et spectateurs qui sont
devenus sourds hier soir la prochaine
spéciale sont mes chers amis l'heure est
grave une terrible affaire secoue la
france depuis quelques jours on vous
raconte tout ça dans un nouvel épisode
peut être le dernier de bama calif
oui parce qu'après c'est l'avenir les
français reprennent goût à la vie ils
peuvent retourner dans les magasins dans
les cinémas ils peuvent boire de la
bière chaude en terrasse sous la pluie
mais alors qu'une tension sanitaire
disparaît une autre apparaît brusquement
c'est vrai qu'elle changeait pas le
compreniez je sais pas ce que c'est
après cette annonce fracassante du
général baba premier les français sont
sous le choc
leur souverain ébranlant sans mauvais
jeu de mots j'ai appelé mon médecin
comme les japonais à pearl harbor en
l'attaqué a été soudaine et violente
mais soixante dix ans après ce sont les
perles de baba premiers qui sont
attaqués c'est la bataille de pearl
harbor l'adar carnet et tracera leur
guide va-t-il remporter cette bataille
baba premier fait appel à la 2e division
blindée
mais même elle est impuissante je n'ai
pas beaucoup et moi alors baba tente une
nouvelle stratégie
il appelle son père il nomme cette
opération baba appelle papa à l'eau ça
va pas très bien
dis moi je suis à l'antenne n'a pas
après un combat sans relâche
finalement la bataille est gagnée j'ai
du mal ça va mieux mais à peine cette
victoire savourée une autre attaque au
même endroit sensible intervient sur le
fonds italien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le général baba pourtant habituellement
bon sniper se tire lui même une balle
dans son propre slip en mauvaise posture
il décide alors d'ouvrir des
négociations si je t'ai venir ce soir
devrait avoir une semaine pour trouver
un italien important qui peut me gracier
shadows me faire un essai de yann et
voté à la place alors le général baba
gagnera-t-il la bataille italienne nommé
la copa del coucougnettes à vous le
saurez en regardant les prochains
épisodes de babak alips j'aime beaucoup
franck appietto